I went on a magical trip that changed my
life forever
and this is that story so it's Labor Day
weekend 2016 and my friend tells me she
has an update on my ex so I'm just like
oh my god what's going on does he have a
girlfriend already she tells me no no
girlfriend so I am relieved but then she
tells me that he recently went to Japan
that pissed me off so much because my ex
does not like to travel I had to book
all of our trips together he went to
Puerto Rico we went to Mexico City it
was all because of the work that I did
to plan these trips and one of the big
trips I wanted to do for us was to go to
Tokyo it's been my dream trip since I
was a kid so fueled my Instagram
jealousy I ran back to my apartment and
immediately began googling trips to
Japan I found round-trip tickets for
$750 whoo then I texted my childhood
friend Pat and I told about this crazy
cheap deal that I found he was down I
was down we decided to spend two weeks
in Japan a month after we booked our
flights my father was hospitalized due
to complications with diabetes I was
with my dad at the hospital for most of
the time and I assumed the role of the
caregiver because my mother is a nanny
and she does not have the same
flexibility as I do work in here
buzzfeed we received the heavy news that
he was diagnosed with kidney cancer I
never thought that I'd be in a situation
where either my parents would have
cancer I took my dad to two different
oncologists they both agreed he needed a
tumor removed from his left kidney I
somehow miraculously got him into one of
the best hospitals in the country but I
was getting nervous the trip to Japan
was getting closer and closer and I
wasn't at work a lot and I asked my boss
at one point should I still go to Japan
is that okay she said please go you need
to travel and get your mind off things
and with my family and boss's blessing I
hopped on a plane with my friend Pat and
we embarked to the Land of the Rising
Sun we started our trip in Kyoto which
is Japan's aging capital it has
thousands of temples and shrines so we
decided to book an all-day tour so we
can hit up all the important spots
obviously at the time I had a lot going
on my life
and also a very spiritual person so it's
important to me when I was in Kyoto to
pray in these temples and shrines and
doing a very respectful manner at the
end of this tour I'm totally nerding out
I'm in the front of the group asking all
the annoying questions raising my hand
it got to a point where I was that
person holding the tour guide pole I was
that tourist and all of a sudden I
noticed this cute guy and I think he's
looking at me at one point we locked
eyes and then I looked away because I
just thought he was staring at me
because I looked crazy with that tour
Pole thing so we're at the last stop of
the tour and it's this magical temple
called Q Mizzou Dera it's absolutely
stunning there are these two stones and
they're actually called the love stones
and legend goes that you must close your
eyes and walk from one stone to another
stone and if you're able to walk from
one stone to another stone with your
eyes closed without any help that means
you won't need help finding love however
if you off from one stone to the other
stone and you need help
you will need help finding love whether
it's a matchmaker your mom tinder you're
gonna need help so my friend Pat walks
from one stone to the other they're
about 60 feet apart and he is flawless I
do it and I'm a hot mess I trip I
stumble
yeah in other words I desperately need
help finding love before we knew it it
was time to head back to the tour bus
and go back to our hotels so as I get
back in the bus
I noticed that that really cute guy who
I thought was checking me out
he was sitting the back of the bus - it
was weird because he definitely wasn't
sitting the back of the bus throughout
the whole day of this tour so here I'm
talking about traveling and where he's
been in Japan so I turn around and start
talking to him we're hitting it off he
introduced himself as Josh I told him I
was Alexis and then I quickly introduced
them to Pat but I made sure to say this
is my friend Pat so he knew I was
traveling with a homie and not a
boyfriend so then I gave my Instagram
handle and I told him to follow me which
he did I became friends with this girl
named Molly from Australia and we made
plans to hang out that night so I
figured I'd asked Josh to join us cuz
he's also an Aussie why not
Molly Josh and I mean the hotel lobby
that evening and I lead them to this
really cool ramen place that I found on
Yelp we had a great meal inside to get
drinks afterwards which is where things
took a turn after a few hours in a bar I
propose that we do karaoke because Japan
is the birthplace of karaoke you know
that chemistry you have when you go out
with a crush your arms are brushing each
other
your legs are rubbing next to each other
and you feel that spark in the air
that's how it felt
singing with Josh Molly finally leaves
to go to the bathroom the second Molly
leaves a room Josh and I begin looking
each other and we just start immediately
kissing 4:00 a.m. rolls around and we
leave the karaoke bar after we dropped
off Molly Josh and I headed straight to
his hotel the next morning we woke up
together and ate a hungover lunch at
McDonald's we ended up spending the
whole day together and we've really
opened up about our lives he tells me
that his parents are both cancer
survivors so I told about my dad's
recent cancer diagnosis and we really
really really bonded over that Josh and
I spent 36 hours together and the only
reason we stopped hanging out was
because he had to go back home to
Australia I still had a week left in
Japan so I finally met up with tad again
for him all the while Josh and I kept
talking on whatsapp it felt like he was
my boyfriend even though he wasn't
eventually my trip to Japan ends I'm
back in New York City a few random guys
my past asked me to hang out and it
frustrated me these boys were playing
themselves I hadn't heard from them in
months and they just started popping up
on my trip after Japan and it just gave
me clarity that really the only person
he wants to be with was Josh a few days
later I was on the phone with Josh and I
just told him the truth I was like look
I only want to be with you and no one
else oh my god I was feeling the same
way if I was in a wait until Christmas
to tell you that he said it felt really
nice that we were both in the same page
so we both laughed and like decided then
and there that after 36 hours of hanging
out he was my boyfriend and I was his
girlfriend fast forward to a month later
my father was about to get surgery to
have his tumor removed my father is a
man of God and I grew up in a Baptist
Church and I really respect and love the
power of prayer but nothing had prepared
me for my father's surgery update a few
days after surgery my father's doctor
called and he said that my dad's tumor
was benign I thought back to two things
I distinctly prayed for in Kyoto first
was my father's health I I prayed for a
speedy recovery like I wouldn't be the
optimistic woman that I am today if it
wasn't for him so that was a really it
was a really important prayer in Kyoto
the second thing I prayed for in Kyoto
was true love so here I am my mid-30s
and I prayed to find true love no matter
my age I was like if I find true love my
40s or 50s or 60s I'd be okay with it I
just want to find the right person I'm
sure you're wondering what's going on
with Josh and I now well
I end up going to Australia to meet his
friends and family and he came to New
York City to meet mine less than a year
after we met he moved to LA we got
engaged exactly a year after we met we
went to the Beverly Hills courthouse and
got married and it only cost us $90 to
get married what a steal I never gave up
on love and it led me to where I am now
I hope the one thing you can take away
from this video is to do the same don't
give up on love
[Music]